I had a purpose I wanted to be one of
the best basketball players to ever play
and anything else that was outside of
that lane I didn't have time for if your
practices aren't more competitive than
the games themselves you're doing the
wrong thing
that's what tap-dancing lessons no
kidding
I took tap and tap was like the best
training for me in the world
given what you did doing that game made
me realize I believe all these just not
feel on them
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one work on your weaknesses at 13 years
old I played the longer game because my
game wasn't about being better than you
at 13 it was it be better than you when
you know the chips are really on on the
line so when we played at 13 I would
size you up and see what your strengths
and weaknesses are how do you approach
the game are you silly about it are you
goofy about it are you good at it just
because you're bigger and stronger than
everybody else right as they're actually
fought and skill that you put into it
right and when I play I play to my
weaknesses I wouldn't play to my
strengths I play to my weaknesses
because when you're playing summer
basketball there's so many games so
there's not a lot of skill work being
done so when are you going to get better
right when you're playing in competition
situations you're only playing To Your
Strengths why because you want to win
right so what I would do I was work on
the things during those games that I was
weak at left hand pull-up jump shot post
game right so I have a strategy and so
then fast forward to when I'm 17 and my
game is completely well-rounded and that
player at 13 that I saw a 13 is still
doing the same 17 now you got a problems
right also if you want to have more
confidence check out my 254 series
they're free the links to join are in
the description below you start with
what do you want your game to be will we
make your game most unstoppable or hard
to deal with if you wake up in the
morning and you're dreading going to
work dude do something else do something
else and those are hard decisions to
make but when you make those decisions
it's a very liberating experience or to
go play someplace else to try to chase a
championship that's not me man that's
not being that's not what my career has
a bit about rule number two study
success kind of take us behind kind of
the current with Michael was there ever
a moment that you guys spoke that you
felt like it energized you you learned
from him yeah it was it was crazy man
cuz my favourite player was magic
growing up mmm and then I quickly
realized my father stole all my height I
was gonna be a 69 point guard so I did
you know so look at this young guy come
and the thing that I marvel that wasn't
the fact that he was getting to the rim
and doing these fancy stuff it was like
how is he getting to the rim how is he
doing it right you look at the footwork
look at the fundamentals
forget the spacing the pacing right and
all those little things the angles and
that's what becomes fascinating it's
like okay how do I get there
all right so I started studying all
those basics and then when I came to
lead the first time I played against
home I won his respect because it was
like this kids not scared of me at all
mm-hmm right and he saw a kindred spirit
from that standpoint and that started a
relationship and it became something
where it was like text him anytime hits
me right back questions hits me right
back and when talking all the time rule
number three push through the pain it
was kind of the perfect series playing
the Celtics then being this annoyed and
then you know the probably five I mean
we joke about that a lot but the most
important thing was beating Celtics
because of everything that they'd meant
to this organization
it was a tough series from it most
people know this but I had a bone spur
mic and then a couple games in Boston
had to leave the game go back in the
locker room and get injected because I
could barely walk and had a broken
finger and I was playing with had to
cast my right thing and then I was
having to deal with Garnett Pierce Ray
Allen Rondo Vashi watt I mean all these
guys and having to figure out how to get
through that series and so it was a big
relief to win first and foremost relief
to win and get out of that series love
if I lost to the Celtics manag I've been
miserable rule number four have a strong
purpose trivial things weren't gonna
pull my attention I had to be Saints
weren't gonna pull my attention it had
to be things that were I had a purpose I
wanted to be one of the best basketball
players to ever play and anything else
that was outside of that Lane I didn't
have time for at what age did that goal
become crystal clear down there I made
that deal with myself at 13 years old at
13 years 13 years old I made clear about
it crystal clear and what did
inspiration come from
the love of the game the love of the
game the challenge like I would watch
magic play I'd watch Michael play and I
would see them do these unbelievable
things and I say you know can I get to
that level
oh no but let's find out rule number
five be a great teammate he was a year
there oh three where I had 40 points in
nine straight games Shaq was out it was
a toe thing so Phil comes to me for
distressed as Kobe we need you to take
over the offense Mike all right cool so
that's really no more I got it I got it
so that literally started the streak of
40 straight game you know 40 points in
nine straight games Shaq comes back from
injury and Phil goes you know I still
continue to do it right and then Phil
calls me to his office goes eh you know
we're starting to lose the big fella
do you mean well he's not getting the
attention you know this this forty point
streak is starting to kind of take away
his fire hmm to prove something right so
I need you to start dialing it back I'm
like what says we're gonna lose him and
we need him in June okay all right you
have a game against the Clippers yeah
like 38 or something like that I chance
to score 40 and they get 40 again it's a
blowout game like dump the ball on the
Shaq instead of shooting a wide-open
shot a 40 point streak ended that night
Wow that was it and that's inside stuff
that people don't know right are you
happy yeah cuz Phil was like hey we got
a dollar back got a dollar back we
started it was the big fella perfect
Kobe - you're like he's like you got to
dial it back you like our I'll score 38
instead of 40 well I mean there's a
street thing with equipment in a row
right local record right right right I
would have broke the record but instead
you know rule number six nurture good
relationships we're gonna reunite the
two of you back together get on
Valentine's Day
young man so Mary
I felt good to play with you again the
does I have Flash Brooks felt great if
the game was real easy we read each
other very easily and it was a it was
fun to kind of it'll go back to memory
lane you believe when he says was off
media ploy by him to grab attention and
take pressure off for your big cheese
marketer yeah you should say that all
the time
[Music]
Kobe Bryant Shaquille O'Neal Coe MVPs of
all-star 2009
I know you're not exactly the
sentimental type but when you guys are
having the interaction on the court feel
like old times a little bit does it make
you a little bit at all wistful for
being able to play with Shaq having
those those moments do you remember what
you did during that game to make the
realize I'll believe all these just you
know feeling them so we got the : vp
it's me and sharif and you said on stage
would you gentlemen told me to take the
trophy no I Friday
yeah I did and I took it home when I
gave it to Sharif fountain and I
realized I was like I think I may have
messed something up because a lot of
times that our beef was going on you
know me I'm the master marketer about 6
percent of time was just saying just to
keep it going but like when you did that
when you didn't have to do that cuz you
know usually take it an email at brands
like Shaq you know you know Sharif love
sure he goes Sharif you gave me Sophie I
just said to myself I was like luckily I
won three out of four this guy thought I
was a to this guy so I owe you an
apology or Miggy apology booing I'll be
doing all that crying but thank you for
that moment because I felt that moment
was the first time I was able to give
him something he was there I was going
through a lot at that time you know he
loved you for it I love you for that one
so very clever
thank you rule number seven focus on one
thing do you think one of the edge you
had over everybody else was the biggest
percentage of your focus was on one
thing do you see it that way like that
was my edge over everybody else I do at
the time I didn't really understand that
right so you know basketball for me was
the most important thing so everything I
saw whether it was TV shows whether it
was books I read people I talked to
everything was done to try to learn how
to become a better basketball player
everything everything and so when you
have that point of view then literally
the world becomes your library to help
you to become better at your craft rule
number eight work the hardest I read a
story that you used to play
guys to a hundred you do be like you
have to stay in this gym and play me to
a hundred and I mean what was the
biggest margin of victory you'd ever
went when high school used to spy guys
99 no kid but you know listen these
prizes practices are meant to be
competitive they're meant to be
competitive if your practices aren't
more competitive than the games
themselves you're doing the wrong thing
mm-hmm
and most of these teams and coaches have
gotten into a mindset of resting players
oh it's too much you know we're not
gonna practice light daylight daylight
they feel never gave us a light day
there's no days off you show up and you
work in practice yeah and practices are
going to be worse it ought to be more
physical there's gonna be more
trash-talking now I'm gonna let you know
right yeah you're gonna show up today
I'm gonna let you know yeah it's gonna
be embarrassing you're gonna hate it
but when Game seven rolls around the NBA
Finals you will be prepared remember
nine
be a problem-solver how do you see dance
and other art forms and athletics in
alignment with one another well there
was a there was a year played Indiana
Pacers in the finals I rolled my ankle
really bad Jalen Rose stepped under me
on purpose he admits it now finally
broke my ankle really really bad I came
back finish the series but I couldn't
touch a basketball till mid-september
which was driving me crazy I couldn't
train but I looked at this was like the
10th time I rolled my ankle and in one
season so I'm looking at that I'm saying
okay I got to address that and so being
that I couldn't get on the basketball
court what I did was I took tap-dancing
lessons no kidding I took tap and tap
was like the best training for me in the
world because it strengthened my feet it
changed my rhythm and my approach to the
game I was able to change speeds when I
came back the following season you know
I think dancers put way more strainer in
their body than athletes do and I think
there's a lot that can be learned from
that my daughter took ballet for several
years and I was sit there in the class
right and I didn't know what I was
getting into his out anything about that
way right but I'm sitting there in the
class and I'm watching her and why
should I get the first position the
second position
I'm learning the structure and the rules
that go along with that and as athletes
there's a lot to be learned from them
because if you simply go out there
perform and play yeah you'll be great
every now and then but if you play with
the structure if you understand the
rules that come along with that the
discipline that comes along with that
then you reach another level but you
guys have my respect if the other people
don't see that there it is that's all no
and rule number ten the last one before
a very special bonus clip is have fun
the jersey retirement and I'm walking
out and we were in a playoff race and
the hunting is going south they were
walking out and I gave you destiny I
love you
congratulations everything and I was
happy for you you know but I couldn't
help but say you know this night has
made a lot sweeter because I know you
have four and I have five this type of
do or how could you ever seen
better that hold on we're gonna take you
pretty sure - here give them five and
give me four
[Music]
[Music]
now I have a special bonus krypton Kobe
on how to have a kill list that I think
you're gonna enjoy but before that it's
time for the three-point landing
question let's go from just watching the
video to taking action here we go
question number one what's the one thing
you need to focus on this week number
two who are three people whose success
you will study today and number three
what is your strong purpose and if you
like this video and you're gonna take
action after watching it give me a
hashtag to leave down the comments as
well
13 years old I had a I had a kill list
and so you know they used to do these
rankings who Street and Smith basketball
rankings and I was nowhere to be found
cuz I was like six four scrawny like 160
pounds soaking wet so I was like 57 on
the list and so I will look at 56 55 all
the way up to number one who these
players are with club teams they played
for so when we're going to a you travel
circuit I got to hunt them down right
and so that became my mission in high
school is to check off every other
person all those 56 other names hunt
them down and knock them down
that was it had a target on him right
off the bat I was it very simple that's
unbelievable
if you want more Kobe check at the top
fifty rules video I made on him the link
is right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there
follow your passion first first first
first first first I had a summer where I
play basketball when I was like 10 or 11
years old
a rock home